good morning everyone I'm luca and this
video in reality I should have put it
at the end not from the beginning and not at the
end because in it several videos before in
which he speaks other languages problem that in the end I
am carried away by the applied craving to sp
ak foreign languages becau
that was the reason why it didn't
actually
start out of pennies so that I was in barcelona
at the end I saw started to see
these videos of languages on youtube because I am pa
sionate about bilingual and in the end she f
und some interesting things for which
there was a video in which a guy
posed himself maira a bit so he said I
speak this this and this other
I think I said they too go a bit a bit
of tongues so I said goodbye
I do this video moment I see it  on
youtube then we see what happens and
he has received a lot of messages
which I liked more than anything else is the
fact that people ask me in
personal messages why  it is the compliments
are nice but the thing I
like most is the fact people have
friends years ago ask me a lot of questions
about done a but how did you
learn the method you use and therefore I
apart from the fact that it stops
copper Italian because I speak Italian
so let's see how you speak your language
they asked me precisely these things about
this general information on the cores
on the various courses and here I wanted to tell you in
general you like foreign languages
found myself very well with
the de agostini course was not
clearly but I say what
I used that I loved to die with
that I used with the exact same
course both a Spanish and
German English and French are a separate
category  in this case because
I learned them when I don't say when
I was little because in any case 10 years old and
from the school she speaks English and French but
the French teacher in middle school
was not bad but the English one was  a
disaster and that I have practically
learned nothing then at 13 I remember
that there was a triggering event in
mine in this very rare of these
wishes she hid inside me and that
was the fact that my aunt she is also a
good polyglot  he gave me a book
I had always been there saying I
would like to learn English well finds an
end
I never had a way indeed I was also
discouraged on seeing that the
teacher had taught me
absolutely nothing in three years she
accumulated little or little knowledge
at the  at the end this book of mine was not
a kind of culture shock I
started reading it and I loved it
and then I started with a
teacher who having her chicago an
American girl greeting with oars is
being too happy not having her age
because she is back in  in the
United States she taught me English for a
year and she had this enthusiasm
for me I for her so
this enthusiasm a recipr  I know that he
created a beautiful thing that
I started learning English a
great enthusiasm I started to
see films read books but in
industrial quantities of tuam I was small I
dedicated myself more now not in time but
before truly English it was really a thing
that excites me but there
were
n't there were no DVDs there were no
tapes that he went to buy at
newsstands for 30 thousand lire
but tomorrow I remember the satisfaction that
was there I was putting on lily in short
, I also learned French  basically
or next time my profession knows
very good French and that
of middle school as a good one that of skilled
extraordinary being south bank and greeting
and she too can make it from the
French language and then I started
watching television because thank god there is
the stop because it is the canal now
I don't have it anymore but just as I
explained how I am there is no canal I
don't know why but if it jumped to my house and
then I give p  ro from 16 years and 18 I
took great advantage of it to learn as
much as possible I have nothing to do with the apparatus
in short enough well then now a
French girl microban every day
and day with tremors no but then and then
having seen English French or seen
that um
in  newsstand came out in 1900 minute
1996 succeeded a course of agostini indeed
four races in the dvr four languages and impor
ant euro for I said to myself but why n
t the relatives of the spas begin
with a bit of difficulty but then in th
end he gave everything to  big
thanks to my dedication it is
true but also to the fact that that course is
a fantastic thing reused the year after
the same course because my
classmate but if I succeed even a
Spaniard gave me this booklet
look at it is one equal to that  to
German I take advantage of it nor German to
work then I also do the
Spanish one and then other languages came as a
esult the Dutch spoke it after
all contest it for  a
girl i met swedish because
my ex girlfriend uploaded a course because she
knew i liked languages and russi
n we lose europ
an i wanted to learn now i am learn
ng portuguese than chinese which still
fascinates me to death portu
uese it is not difficult if you are alrea
y  Spanish for Chinese ownership so
that I'm just reading these
things is making me pour all these different
tones for this
incredible writing and now nothing I just wanted to
add the fact that
apart from talking about the fact
that I have learned  languages
ing I wanted to say is that the advic
I give penetrates into languages I am not a language te
cher but they are very practical,
hat is, they are basically constancy just do a 4
a day here because three hours for t
ree consecutive days if for an even year a
d  then to write down the things to
transcribe as if you want to
ask him questions about which just as an equal I am
more than available and then do  a lot of
attention to the sounds at the beginning when you
take a language
there are a lot of things of the core to
add but you can not however less a
bit of lies
so no thanks for listening to me
if you want to go and see
my videos that officially proposed
violant and  thank you very much
bye bye everyone